hello and welcome to this video playing
soft clay f em softly same deals or
chess player clicks have fun okay you
have the Devils in Cairo taking the
Queen okay this is quite unusual the
ones that a threat it looked like a
threat but he didn't react to it
yeah the opening result is just
fantastic for white one already has a
very substantial advantage which is no
one I just kept playing move instantly
but not paying any attention what's
going on so what I've seen the problem
is that this structural weaknesses just
never will go away racine I just have
this fantastic structure oh that's a
good move it's a good move so that 95
gets possible I don't want to play
Bishop f4
oh I'm should h6 was good this is
against somewhat playable for black
still not good but it was much worse
before I and we'll look this I have to
reorganize this a little bit you should
see one Bishop T 2 and so on all the
bishop on beach was in good
[Music]
well they never will go away those pawns
I mean they will go away when I take
them but I think I can just take it
a black completely falling apart here
and when the bishop d5 is also good so
maybe maybe quicker yeah I think this is
this is probably the easiest one taking
the Queen down I can offer take on d5
and play Queen default this looks the
eight coming here no I mean yes but I
can go to deform doesn't really hurt I
may be in for food and now threatening
you form and then take you 1 x 6
playing before breakfast and cocaine
[Music]
yeah it is absolutely no counter plays
the problem is the tons of material down
and no counter plane okay let me just
III or something and when it cannot take
on it to anyway
I could have taken h7 actually okay okay
it just takes the 8 24 or denim maybe
this one I've certainly more than one
way to win we're also thinking look g7
as a threat iam no it's not course not
sorry might be if he moves the bishop
track somewhere but he has most gladly
go to queen d 50 in the threat and then
coming to f7
check yes check yes check blog for pics
on time yeah okay so let's have a look
there now what I absolutely never
understand this how people can play
moves like that in two seconds but this
is an old story that I keep repeating
and I know people hate it but then
sometimes people think to have a total
disregard for the first move of the game
like it doesn't matter after 95 the game
is essentially over if I'm not doing
something really wrong black will do it
with the with a bad one
right and terms I really made a bad
mistake in this well okay but he am the
son it is really what's wrong giving him
the opportunity to play Bishop h6 now
we're already being a bit sloppy here
because I felt okay I'm winning this
anyway at the bishop h6 that helped a
little bit yeah I have to reorganize a
little bit now you've got the f6 and so
on invite remains to be better because
simply this is so terrible that you can
play one or two second rate moves like
it's never going to get rid of the pawns
yeah I would doing this we organizing
and here this is refusing
this in the morning and in the morning
that cool is somewhat more persistent
and it gets better one or two hours
later yeah so here this is a mostly
technical exam rook t6 was better now
but ok that's like everything wins yeah
just the opening is just not playable
like that I think in 25 is a little bit
shaky already and why would you why not
just play 95 but if you place for the
engine right between h5 is still kind of
normal maybe this is more precise so
that I have aged three DM possible ok
guys thanks for watching